そういうことで 行動 心
口 意 頭で考える 心で頭で考える
言葉で喋る 体で行動する
その一切の行動の原因は無明であるというすごい巨大な教えなんです
それは究極的な真理なんです
だから英語を知らない
だから英語を勉強するっていうふうな
もう単純なもうくだらない話じゃないんです
これは人間の一切の行動に関係ある
だから なぜ私はあくびをあくびをするんですか？なぜ私は手を伸ばすさいを伸ばしますか？とかね
なぜ私は歩きますか？なぜ私は座ってるんですか？なぜ私は一人でいろいろなことを考えてるか
全ての行為が無明から発生するんです
で 無明がなくなったならば
行為はストップするんです
そこは涅槃の世界 解脱の世界です
そういうわけで 項目でお釈迦様にとっては解脱まで喋られるんです
でもいりません そういうもうすごいからくりなんですね
因果法則っていうのは
私たちは無明から業が生じて
業から業から色が生じてとかね
全部なければと思ってますけど
結局説明すると そうやって項目でももうぴったしセットになっちゃうんです
そこでなぜ無明があるかということは聞かなくてもいいんです
理解し 考えるのはもう無明っていうのは別に特別に現れる特別な状況ではないんです
それは普通の状況ですね
ですから 普通の状況から説明が始まってるんですね
そういうわけで この あの
最初の原因は何ですかと
と仏教では考えてないんですね
それは物事はシークエンシャルで順番で考える人々の
その考え方自体おかしい
鶏は卵から生まれるんだと
それ順番で考える 卵があって
それから鶏が生まれると
それは成り立たないんです
そういうのも 卵という実体があって
卵という実体から鶏が生まれて
それは道樹さんも全部もう成り立たないと否定しているんですね
だから無知な人の考えている原因結果っていうのはシークエンシャルで石が人がいて
石を取る 石を投げる で
窓ガラスに当てて窓ガラスは割れると
順番ちゃんとありますね
時間の過程の中で人がいたと
石を取った時間と投げた瞬間と窓に当たった時間と
で 窓が割れたっていうこと
そうやって時間から追っていくと
最初は何ですかということになっちゃうんですね
で 私たちのその考え方自体間違っているんだということなんです
で あの だからこの時間過程は時間
まあ世俗的には時間というものがありますから
仏教は時間はないんだからね
時間というものまるっきり考えてももうない
時間論もない でないんだけど
やっぱり世俗的にはそれなりの時間というものはありますから
やっぱりシークエンス的には物事は考えられます
順番で 順番で考えると
じゃあ最初の原因見つかりますかと
見つからないでしょうね
それでも 例えばこれがこれがあったんだからありますよと
これはもっと前のこれがあったんだからいますよと
これはもっと前のこれ
それでこれは初めだよと言えますかね
それでそれがもっと前の何かから始まらなくちゃいけませんからね
だからシークエンスで考えたってまあいい加減にしなさいと
もう切れがないし 終わりがないし
無意味である 仏教ではシークエンシャル的なことをほんのちょっとそのちょっと言ってはいますけど
これには言ってない 本当は
なぜならば時間というのは成り立たないもので
どうしても時間的に考えたければ
あなたは無限大に行くだけですと
無限大に行ったらそれにまた先があるんだから
ということで まあだから最初の原因というのはなくなっちゃうんです
原因はあるんだけど 最初の原因
ファーストオリジンというものはなくなっちゃう
オリジナルコースということはなくなっちゃうんです
で この鶏と卵の例で この遡ることは間違ってるっていうことはわかるはずなんですね
なぜかというと 鶏がいて卵があって
その卵の前に鶏がいて
その前にまた卵があって
どんどんどんどん魚を追っちゃうでしょうね
そこで じゃあ最初にあったのは鶏か卵かという問題が作られる
でも違う方向で考えちゃうと
それは成り立たないんですね
それで違う方向というのは
例えば世の中っていうのはね
生命が誕生してどんどんどんどん変化していっちゃいましたから
例えば生命の誕生から進化過程と
鶏は確実に卵から生まれるよという真理はどうやって合体できますかね
もし鶏が確実に卵から生まれるならば
進化論も否定しなくちゃいけない
だからそこら辺どこか考え方がおかしいということは出てきますね
もともとはね もう鶏もいなかったし
卵もいなかったんだから
だから鶏と卵の論で この人間はアダムというとか
なんとかところで現れたということに言わざるを得なかったんですね
それは科学的な事実とはまるっきり違う
どうせ考え方は間違ってますからね
私がいるのは両親がいたんだから
両親がいたのはそちらの両親がいたんだから
それじゃない そういうやつをちゃんと普通の数学で考えちゃうと
どんどんどんどん人口がすごく増えるはずなんですけど
私の両親二人でしょう
その二人が四人だから
だからどうしてもぴったし四人
八人に八人 十六人に増えなくても
兄弟も何人か現れる場合もありますからね
やっぱり人口は増えてしまっちゃうんですね
じゃあ二人から現れ できて増えるっていうことはまた逆にありえないんですね
二人の男と女がいて それ子供を産んで
その子供がお互いに結婚しなくちゃいけないんだから
それも科学的に成り立たないでしょう
結局そうでしょうしね
まあ二人だけいて そこで子供は何人か作ると
その何人かがまた互いにきょうだい結婚しなくちゃいけないし
それだったらどうやって白人と黒人とモンゴ人がいるんですかね
ですから この人間というのはなんか単純に考えてすごい哲学やって言うんだ
それは信じる人に僕は文句言いたいんだけどね
言う人は言えば構いませんだけど
とにかく因果法則というのは
そういうすべての問題に応えているんです
だから そういうのはこのシークエンシャルで物を考えて
そんなことを言ってるし
だからある時間の軸で物事を考えるとも見えてくるのは終わりがないと
終わりというと始めがないという結果なんです
で そこは難しいんだから置いておいて
アウィッジャーによってサンカーラが
行が 働きが 行為が生まれるというところを見ても
綺麗にまとめているんじゃないかではないかとわかるはずなんです
アウィッジャーというのは無知ということだから
無知はなぜあるかと聞いたって勉強してないんだからと簡単に言いますからね
勉強というのはこれからするもんだからね
だから知らない状態なんですね
あるのは だから知らないんだから
すべて知るということは成り立ちますけど
人間も知らないことに気が付かなかったら頑張れないんですね
田舎で生まれずっと田舎で育てる人は英語を勉強しなきゃ困っちゃうなってことを気にしませんだから
だからその人にはその問題には気が付かない
そこで東京に 江戸に来たところで
やっぱり いろいろ人に触れたりすると
誰かに道というのを聞いた
聞かれたところでやっぱり気が付くんですね
初めて知らないんだと
私は無知 無明だと それで行動を起こして知るということになっちゃうんですね
ですから無知はみんなにあるんだから
論理的にはみんな一切智者になれるはずなんです
無知っていうのは何も知らない状態だから
それによってすべて知るということにはなりたしますけど
でも だからといって皆一切智者にはならないんですね
なぜならば気が付いてないんですね
だから気がつく分はなんとかわずかな智慧が生まれます
だから人間持っている知識っていうのは
それは無知に気がついた部分だけなんですね
よりより深く自分の無知に気がつくと
より知識も智慧も発達していくんです
でもそれひとつも動力なしに努力なしには成り立たない
だからよし わかりました
私は無知だとよく理解しましたと理解しただけで智慧が生まれるわけじゃないんですね
行動を起こさなくちゃいけないんです
ですから この そういうわけで
無知が完全に消えたら
行が完全に消える 行動はすべて消えるということは
そこでそれっきりはもう人はいない
生命はいない もう解脱なんですね
で 二つ目 サンカーラ パッチャヤ ヴィンヤーナ
[背景の物音]こっち
まあ続けて説明できますけど
このサンカーラということは行動行為でしょうし
だからその行動する 行為することによってヴィンニャーナというのは知識で識ですね
心ですね 心が生まれてくるというか
心が変化していくということなんですね
行動することによって自分の心が変化していくんですね
だからそれぐらいで理解でいいと思います
まあ心はいつでも まあ一応なければ何も成り立ちません
心がなければアヴィッジャも成り立ちませんだけど
例えばアヴィッジャある時も心がありますけど
その心が無明だと分かったところで行動が起こす
行動する時も心で行動するであって
それで行動によって心はまたその同じ心が変化していっちゃうんですね
だから 前の分かりやすい例えに戻ってみると
英語を勉強すると 英語を勉強すると英語の知識というヴィンニャーナが生まれてくるんですね
まあそこまでまあちょっと止まってもらわないと
また伝統的な説明に行かないと
で これから困るんです
今まで言ったのはこの分かりやすい
説明だけで このサンカーラパッチャヴィンニャーナということもこれで終了することもできます
サンカーラっていうのは行動なんですね
だから行動することによって
識というのは人の心っていうものは生まれてくるんですね
だから行動さえやめちゃえば
心の生まれること 続くことは消えてしまうんですね
だから我々には行動をやめることできますよ
一応喋らないでいることぐらいでもできますし
考えれば考えないこともしないようにすることも一応できるし
もうちょっと厳密に考えちゃえば
もう考えることもやめちゃって
行動一切やめるということを何か訓練によってできないわけないんですね
だから行動を停止したということで
ヴィンニャーナが終わっちゃうんです
心が消えてしまうんですね
それ解脱なんですね だから行動によって心が新しい心が生まれてくるんでしょうし
難しいことじゃないんです
我々が何か新しいことをすると新しい
だからこれから降りて一階に行ってジュースでも飲もうかなと思ったら
これ行動でしょうに そうすると
降りる時は新しい心が生まれる
ジュース買う時は新しい心が生まれて
飲む時は新しい心が それ生まれてきて
ここで新しい人生が成り立っちゃうんですね
だから行動することによってヴィンヤーナがずっと続けちゃうんだから
行動をやめない限りはずっとヴィンヤーナが続けちゃうんですね
問題は人に行動をやめられますか？という
やめられないんですね
たとえ 1 秒の 1 億分の 1 ぐらいでも
行動をやめてみてください
やめられませんよ そういうわけで輪廻なんです
終わりがないんですね
では 私はずっと言っているように考えてはいけません
考えること 知識は全部間違っているんだと
言ってるんだけど 考えてるでしょうに
時々僕は証明まで出して考えたならば
それはそれで間違っていると
というのは あんた考えたんだから間違っていると
それだったら考えること自体は間違いの行為であって
いい加減考えることをやめればいいでしょうに
どう何を考えたって間違いですからね
じゃあこれから正しく考えましょうということ成り立ちませんでしょうに
考える行為は間違いの行為だよと言われたならば
ああ わかりました これから正しい考えは成り立ちませんでしょうに
ですから じゃあ考えることをやめましょうと言ったってもやめませんでしょうね
かえって心配するんです
ヴィパッサナー瞑想なんかやっちゃうと考えることできなくなっちゃいますから
これで大丈夫かと だからその質問もおかしいんですね
だからヴィパッサナーやることで心配であるなら
ヴィパッサナーしないあなたは何も心配しなかったんですかと聞きたくなっちゃうんですね
あんた人生何も心配しなかったなら
なんで私のところに来たんですかと
だから本人が考えているでしょう
その考え方は間違っているんですね
だからヴィパッサナーのこと知らない人が来たっていうことは
人生大変で 何か心配事があったんだからでしょうに
ですから その考え方とは全く違う考え方を教えたら
これで心配やと言うでしょうに
だからこの 考えること自体が間違っているということなんですね
ですから この行動をやめましょうと言ってもやめられないんだから
いつでも色という寿命っていうのは寿命というか
生命としてずっとまあ生まれて生まれて生まれて生まれていっちゃうんですね
で そこでもう解脱のとこまでこのセットで終わっちゃうんです
そういう経典が 1つあります
項目つなげて言うんじゃなくて
項目いって そこで涅槃まで終わってしまっちゃう
次の項目に行って そこで涅槃まで解脱まで終わってしまっちゃうと
そういう経典もあります
で 伝統的なアビダンマになると
このアウィッジャーっていうのはやっぱり無明なんですけど
サンカーラっていうのはやっぱり業なんですね
身口意の行動なんですね
でもそれも行動は行動なんですけど
とにかく業なんですね
そこで業によって色が生まれると
という場合は この新しい生まれだそうです
だからこれ今も同じなんですね
今も行為によって新しい心が生まれる
それ今も分かります それは絶対的真理だから
どこにでも当てはめると
今も行為によって新しい心が生まれて生まれてきりがなく生まれていくことはわかってますから
そこで人が死んだということにします
死んでもその人は無明ですからね
無明を持っているんだから
死ぬこと自体も行為なんですね
だったら新しいヴィンヤーナが生まれるはずなんです
なぜならば 行為によってヴィンヤーナが生まれることはもう絶対的な真理だから
それは絶対的な真理であることは
最初からもうお釈迦様の方程式からわかるはずでしょうし
日常生活のことを理解するとわかるんですね
無明でなければ行が生まれませんだからね
英語を完全に知っている人は英語は勉強しませんだから
英語を知らない人は英語を勉強するんだから
英語を勉強することによって新しい行動が生まれて
新しい考え方が生まれると
新しい人間が生まれるんだと
それはもう避けられない事実
ですから 無明あるということは
心が新しく生まれるということになっちゃうんですね
その方程式をもっと違うところに当ててみる
人が死ぬと 死ぬまでずっと行為をしてきたんですね
心が生まれてきたんですね
死ぬこと自体も行為でもあるし
無明の人であるし ですから
その人の行 働きが心作らずにはいられないんです
確実に心が作られるんですね
これはもう避けられない
因果法則だから そういう論理を持ってアビダンマの世界では
この過去世で人が無明があるんだから
いろんな行為をして業を積み重ねちゃう
業を積み重ねちゃうと
死んでも次に新しい場所でヴィンニャーナが現れてしまっちゃうんだと
これ同じヴィンニャーナがぐるぐるぐるぐる球のように転がっているわけじゃないんです
それだったら英語を勉強したっても勉強になりませんから
生まれ変わらなきゃ 心が新しくならなきゃダメなんです
だから同じ球が流れている
同じヴィンニャーナという球が
もう過去世から現世まで
現在から将来未来まで流れていくわけじゃないんです
それは我論だから 同じヴィンニャーナだったら
私はいくら勉強したっても何も変わりませんね
変化しませんから だからヴィンニャーナに無知があって
英語を知らないという無知がある
気づいたら勉強すると無知も消えちゃうし
英語を知るというようなことになっちゃうし
だから英語を知っている人と英語を知らない人の苦
随分違いますからね だから心は変化しちゃうんですね
変化するということは
同じ心変化するんじゃなくて
心が死んで その代わりに新しい心が生まれる
その代わりに新しいことが生まれるということを
分析論では説明したと思います
ひと月やると新しい現象が現れますから
そういうことで人が過去世でいっぱい業を積み重ねちゃうし
そのエネルギーで新しいところで生まれ変われるんだという風に
アビダンマの世界で そこで過去と現在の綱
結び目にしちゃうんです
だから 十二因縁説の説明にはいろいろ説明方法があるということだけ理解してください
私が説明したのは 一般的に誰にでも理解できるところです
こちらはもう ある仏教という教えの中で輪廻を説明しているところで今
そこで新しく人が生まれたとする
次にヴィンヤーナパッチャナーマルーパー
ヴィンヤーナパッチャナーマルーパー
ヴィンヤーナっていうのは色ですね
色によってナーマとルーパが生まれてくるんだと
そちらも説明しなくちゃいけないんだけど
と どうしましょうか まあ色によって名色が生まれるということですね
で 名と色っていうのは
この漢字で見る限りは名前と色は形なんですけどね
で 結局それでもいいという説もあります
これ最近なんですけど
ものにはもう名前があるんじゃないかと
名前っていうのは言葉でもありますからね
で 言葉であるということは認識するってことなんですね
言葉があってもなくても認識するんだから
まあとにかくこの最近の説は
まあ私はちょっとどうかなと思いますけど
まあ一応世俗的な話から説明してから伝統的な話に行きます
例えば我々英語を勉強したとする
ヴィンヤーナも生まれたんだから
英語を勉強して英語を知っているヴィンヤーナ
心ですね それからその人はそれなりに行動するでしょうに
ナーマルーパーっていうのはそういうものなんですね
英語を持って仕事をするわ
いろんな人と会うわ もう英語で外国に行って買い物をするわ
自分で英語がわかるんだから
電話でもかけて外国に
あるいはなんとかインターネットでもいろいろ買い物するとかね
そこで新しい人生が生まれちゃう
新しい世界が生まれちゃうね
その人には 物質的にも生まれてくるし
知識的にも生まれてくる
英語がわかるんだったら
もう英語の本でも読めるでしょうに
それでもう新しい知識が生まれてくるんです
いまだに 一度も読んだことはないんだと
英語のテキストなんか
英語わかるようになったところで
まあなんだかんだ言えるようになってしまうじゃん
だからこの人はヴィンヤーナ使えば使うほどナーマルーパーが生まれる
本読んだらナーマであって
買い物なんかしたら まあしたらもういろいろルーパであるし
ですから 英語を使わない知らない人々は
やっぱり買い物したくたっても
業者がもう外国からもういろいろ品物を買ってきて
一生懸命宣伝して売るときは買うと
そうするとまあかなり時間かかっているし
買ったってももう日本で売っているものだから
まあ別に外国から買ったものだというふうに
なんとなくもうその楽しみもなくなっちゃうんです
それである人がもう英語を知っているようになって
それで外国の世界のことも知っているようになってしまって
あ 日本でまるっきりないものあるんですよと
じゃあ買おうと で 買えるでしょうに
その人にはみんなより先にやったという喜びもあるかもしれませんしね
そこら辺次に出ていきますからね
薬の場合も アメリカで新しい薬を開発したっても
あの 日本ではそれ五年
六年かかっちゃうんですね
あの日本で臨床実験いろいろやって許可下りると
それで許可下りたところで薬があって病院使ったって先生面白くも何ともないんですね
それでもう新しい あの薬はダメでしたと
新しい薬は今開発している
開発中やというんだからね
そこで新しい薬を開発しましたといったところで
外国に行く人がそういう言語能力ある人が自分だけのために取り寄せてもらっちゃうところで
じゃあどうだいっていう感じになるでしょうね
他病院でも使ってないんだけど
私はこの薬使ってるんですよ
まあ結果で死んじゃっても
とにかくその人にはまあその喜びがそこにあるんですね
日本の行政制度強化落ちる前にまあできますかと
なんかあの最近昨日か今日かな
あのなんか人捕まってるんですね
あの あのビアグラという薬をね
もう三千二 三千かな 持ってきて
やっぱり三十個までは大丈夫だそうです
個人使用のために 三千はダメと
あれ開発して結構そんな新しいものじゃないの
最近なんか人気あるんだけどな
開発中では僕は論文とか読んでみたんだけどね
で怪しいと でもそれからまるっきり怪しくはないと
また論文が出てきて でも本当はもう未だに知らないと
あれ使ってもいいかないと
とにかくこれは医者が病気の人にあの決める薬なんですね
まあ勝手にとって飲んではいけないこと
まあそれはどうでもいいということで
とにかく心が新しい心が生まれると
新しい行動と知識が生まれてきますね
そういうことで理解しておきましょう
そこで伝統的な解釈に戻っちゃうと
ヴィンヤーナというのは新しいところで生まれた心が現れたということ
で 心が現れたということで
そこにその人には生命としての命と体ですか
そこで現れなくちゃいけないんですね
ですから ナーマっていうのは心でルーパっていうのは体なんですね
で体ですけど いきなり完璧な体が生まれるわけじゃなくて
ルーパは生まれるんだと
物質 何か生まれるんだと
で あの上の二行目は過去生
三行目からは今生で今生で生まれたヴィンヤーナがある
そのヴィンヤーナからどんどん体が現れてくる
そこでナームルーパッチャ サラーヤタマ
私はアビダンマ勉強した時はこの因果法則を教えてくれなかったんですけど
なぜかというと まあそれは今の場所では説明しないんです
ただ名前言うだけ もうとっくに説明してあるんだからね
全部 だからこれこれこれとこれで言うだけで終わっちゃうんです
で ナーマ・ルーパ・パッチャヤー・サラーヤタナン
ナーマ・ルーパっていうのは心と体ですね
で その心と体からはサラーヤタナン
六処が生まれるんですね
名色から六処が生まれるんだと
六処っていうのはもう決まっているでしょ
眼耳鼻舌身意 チャック・ソータ・ガーニジワ・カーヤマナ
だからもう目に見えない体で生まれますけど
どんどんそれ成長するし
で 成長したってもナーマ・ルーパだから
その成長する過程でじわじわと目が現れてくるわ
耳が現れてくるわ そういう認識の窓口が現れてきます
だから眼耳鼻舌身意という六つの窓口が現れてくるんだと
仕事多いということなんですね
で 次にいきます サラーヤタナ・パッチャ・パッソ
サラーヤタナ・パッチャ・パッソ
六処から触という触れるということが生まれるんだと
サラーヤタナ は知ってますね
眼耳鼻舌身意 眼耳鼻舌身意があると
やっぱりいろんな情報に触れる
触ですね だから触も六種類あります
目に触れる 耳に触れる
鼻に触れる 舌に触れる
体に触れる 頭の中に概念として触れる
六処が生まれたところで
その人は外の世界と関わりを持つようになる
目があると外の世界があると見える
耳があると外の世界があると聞こえる
味があると外にも世界があると味わえる
で 体で外の世界を触れてみる
頭で考えて外の世界のことを考えてしまうというふうに
外の世界に触れることは成り立つんですね
それをパッサというんですね
で パッサの次はヴェーデナ
パッサ 外の世界に触れた時はヴェーデナ
感覚が生まれる 触れたという感覚が生まれる
この次にヴェーデナ・パッチャ・タンハ
眼耳鼻舌身意 この色声香味触法触れちゃうと
やっぱり感覚が生まれる
ヴェーデナ 受が生まれる
感覚っていうのは受ですね
ヴェーデナ・パッチャ・タンハ
ヴェーデナ 受 感覚からタンハ
渇愛が生まれる それで体が出てきて
体に穴がね 六つの穴が出てきて
六つの穴が出てきたら外の世界に触れる
触れると感じちゃうって
感じたところでもう渇愛が
欲が生まれてくる これ一つ一つ丁寧にセットセットにして説明した方が因果法則の理解はすごく幅広くなりますけども
まあ時間の関係もありますしね
タンハ・パッチャ・ウパーダナ
この渇愛が生まれたならば
ウパーダナ 固執 固く なんていいます